si defendió hasta el final y luego a
seguir defendiendo a pesar de que osama
bin laden fue asesinado no en afganistán
sino en pakistán en el 2011 y a pesar de
haber dado estos golpes bélicos precisos
no ven la distancia no en pakistán eeuu
siguió en afganistán diez años más
entrenando educando y armando a miles de
personas y analistas lo que están
diciendo en eeuu es que precisamente la
presencia de eeuu continua después de
haber cumplido su objetivo de acabar con
osama bin laden le dio ese resurgimiento
ese impulso para que los talibanes pues
empezarán a crecer se revivieron y hoy
pues tomen el control total de
afganistán